don't worry we cannot leave you without
showing you dolly parton's hot girl
summer video to celebrate the birthday
of her husband carl dean
megan the stallion and jody turner smith
have both both voiced their love
for this yes our country queen recreated
one of her most
iconic looks wearing a pair of bunny
ears and a variation of the outfit she
wore
on the cover of playboy back in 1978
and for that we will always love you
dolly
check it out and we will see you next
time
bye hey today is july 20.
it's my husband carl's birthday and
you're probably wondering why i'm
dressed like this well it's for my
husband's birthday
remember sometime back i said i was
going to pose on the playboy magazine
when i was 75.
well i'm 75 and they don't have a
magazine anymore
but my husband always loved the original
cover
of playboy so i was trying to think of
something to do to
make him happy he still thinks i'm a hot
chick
after 57 years and i'm not going to try
to talk him out of that
and i hope he agrees what do you think
anyway what i did for his birthday i did
a little photo shoot
in this little outfit and um
i had a cover made of
the new dolly or the old new dolly
and in the first one steve remember this
i was kind of a little butterball in
that one
well i'm string cheese now but he'll
probably think i'm cream cheese
i hope anyway i'm going to surprise him
going in singing to him
in my little bunny suit so what do you
think